[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]
NICK BUTCHER: Hello, everyone.
And welcome to my talk
today, Motional Intelligence.
Where I'm going to tell you
all about how to build smarter
animations.
My name is Nick Butcher.
And if this would click onward.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
NICK BUTCHER: Here we go.
My name is Nick Butcher.
I am an engineer on the Android
Developer Relations team.
And I focus mostly on UI
design and development.
So I spent a lot of
time on the main thread.
I'm going to go through
a lot of code today.
This is IO.
That's what you want, right?
But don't worry about
taking photos of the slides
or worrying about
referring back later.
All of this talk is going to
be uploaded later to this URL
or if you're watching
on the recording,
you can find it
right now, hopefully.
So you can follow
along and they'll
be gifs of codes and everything.
So, today, I want to talk
to you about animations.
I think animations are super
important, #animationsmatter.
Often, I think animations
are thought of as delight,
or polish, or
something sprinkled
on at the end of the
development process.
And I think that's
a massive shame.
And I think that
contributes to the reason
why they're often the first
things on the chopping block
when the time is tight and
features are crunching.
Animations, I think are
really important for usability
of your application.
They can explain a state
change so that the user
knows what's going on.
They can establish
a spatial model
so that you have a sense of
place within the application.
Or they can hint at how
you can interact with them.
So they're very
important, in my opinion.
But I think animations are
currently under threat.
And that's due to
changes in the way
that we are architecting
our applications.
So there's a movement
towards having
the controller of
your application
be outside of the
view layer, right?
And something like
a view model then
publishes a state
of the application.
So the UI model, view state,
whatever you might call it,
is essentially the entire
state of your application
needed to render on the screen.
And as things change
in your back end,
say a network request comes
in or the user performs
an interaction, this updates
the state in your view model
and they publish a new
version of this UI statement.
There's lots of benefits to
this kind of architecture.
Such as being able to reason
about the entire state
of your application at once,
or easier testing, and so
on and so forth.
But I'm not going to
go into those today.
I'll encourage you to check
out uni-directional data
flow or patterns, such as MPI.
Or even libraries,
such as Mavericks,
or Mobius for helping
to implement this.
What I do when I talk
about is the observers
of this stream of
data at the other end.
So when you get these
stream of UI models,
you then need to bind
it into your views
to set these values, to set
up the state of your views.
Now, having the
stream of UI models
is kind of like a pure function.
You want to have this pure
input and perform an action.
It essentially wants
to be very stateless.
On the other side, animations
essentially, are very stateful.
They want to know
all about setting
a value from one value
to another value,
over a period of time.
So this, I think, is the
ultimate tension right now.
With this move to
this new architecture
it's becoming harder
to join these two state
lessons stateful worlds.
So today, I want to focus in on
some tools and some techniques
that you can use in
your applications
right now in order to
enable you to do animations.
Because I think
that it's a shame.
I think a lot of
people are finding
it hard to kind of
square the circle.
To kind of marry
these two models.
And as such, I think
animations are under threat.
So to look at these
tools and techniques,
let's start off with a
simple minimum viable screen.
Where we have some
kind of log on form.
And when you hit log
on, and crucially, I
want to hide the
Login button and show
some kind of progress spinner.
But I don't want it
just to blink out
of visibility and change.
I want it to animate out and
the spinner to animate in.
So the UI model, the
state for the screen,
might look something like this.
A simple data class with a
couple of booleans about what's
going on.
And you can then bind
this into your view layer,
to your application, using
some kind of library functions
like this.
Where set visibility
in this static well,
before we animate it, to
something very simple,
like setting the
views visibility
and based on that boolean state.
So how can we animate
something like this?
So, an initial kind of
naive way to do this,
might be something
like this, where
we're just running an
animation to, in this example,
fade in a view.
Or when we're fading it out,
we have to, of course, set
the visibility to gone.
Because otherwise,
the button stays
present in the hierarchy
receiving touches and so forth.
So we all know this.
We're all androiders.
We have to use
the ALPHA property
and then set the
visibility, as well.
But doing something
like this might
yield interesting results.
Like for example, just doing
that it's actually running.
And you can see every time
I do a key strike here,
you see the spinner kind
of like shows up briefly
and then fades out.
Which is not what I wanted.
Or if I managed to
actually finish the form
and hit the login button,
we see some weirdness
going on where they're
kind of overlapping.
And then, all of the
sudden, both views are gone.
I'm like, what's going on there?
Essentially, what is going
on is with this model,
where lots of updates have
been published at once,
you can get into some
corner cases which you
have to consider ahead of time.
And I actually would
like to propose
three kind of
principles, or tenants,
which would make a good
animation in this world.
Which are that they should
be reentrant, continuous,
and smooth.
Let's look at each of these.
So the first, reentrant, is
a fancy computer science word
for essentially
that your function
should be able to be interrupted
and called again at any time.
So essentially, we're saying,
if it was in this state, where
a new model can be
published at any time
and you're observing it, if
you're running animations,
which also take
a period of time,
you need to be prepared for
a model being published.
And while the animation
is still running,
you need to be able to
respond to them safely.
The second one is continuous.
And if you look at this
example of an animation
here where this view is changing
scale and color as I touch it.
I think it looks fine if I touch
it and it scales to completion.
I let go and it scales
back to normal state.
But if I touch kind
of rapidly, you
can see it's jumping
in scale and color.
And this kind of
discontinuity is very jarring.
It can be very kind of abrupt,
this change to our users.
Which doesn't lead to a very
pleasant user experience.
Essentially, animations
are all about smoothly
changing a value over time.
That's kind of what
an animation is.
If we're not kind of prepared
for this new value coming in
at a certain time,
you can have something
like this, where we're
midway through one curve
and then suddenly
we jump and we have
this discontinuity, which
leads to the most poor user
experience.
And the last tenant I want to
propose is one of smoothness.
And by which I mean,
take this example,
where I'm animating a view
to either the top left
or top right, depending
on pushing this button.
If now I hit the top
right button twice,
you can see it slows down
and then animates again.
Because a new event came in,
it kicked off a new animation.
But because each animation
had the same duration,
it leads to this kind of like
discontinuity in the velocity.
So it slows down.
And this kind of looks
kind of terrible.
Similarly, if I try and retarget
it so it's going one way,
and then I send it
off to the left,
to the left then to the
right, you can see it just
kind of stops suddenly and
then reverses direction.
Now, nothing in the real world
has this instantaneous change
in direction or velocity.
And so this feels
very unnatural to us.
So let's look at solving
these problems in our code.
So first up, let's take a look
at that continuous property
that it jumped midway through.
And you can see here that I've
kind of made some assumptions.
That when you want
to show something
that I'm going to
animate its visibility,
it's ALPHA properties.
So from zero to
one or one to zero.
So this is kind of
making the assumption
of the current value.
What we can do with
animators instead,
is just remove
that initial value.
So just say animate
to this value.
And the way the object animator
and property system works
is the property
here, ALPHA, both
tells you how to set
the kind of animated
value on the view, as well,
but also offers how to get it.
So if you omit
the from value, it
will read the
views current ALPHA
and it'll start from there,
which is what we want.
We don't want the
value to jump around.
So that was easily solved.
But let's take a look at
the reentrant problem.
That's slightly thornier.
So the reentrant
property essentially
is that we want to be able
to call this at any time
and not have any kind of side
effects lingering around.
So, essentially, what we need to
do is clean up after ourselves.
We need to kind of cancel
any running animation that's
going on.
But, if you look
at this code here,
we're not actually holding a
reference to the animations,
right?
We just create them,
and call start, and then
forget about them.
There's no reference
held onto it.
So what we can do is fix that.
Actually, first,
before that, then let's
not run an animation
if we don't need to.
So in that instance, where I
was typing, typing, typing.
And it was all
those times saying,
I want the spinner
to be invisible.
It was always running
that animation.
But we want to actually
skip that animation
if you don't need to.
So here, what we're simply doing
is saying, if we are targeting,
if we're going to
go fade out to zero,
if it's already faded out, just
return early, so bail early.
So short circuit the method.
But if we wanted to cancel
a running animation that's
kind of like mid
progress, then we
need to kind of
store it somewhere so
that we can have access to
the animator to cancel it.
Such that when a new
invocation comes around,
we can cancel any running
animations before setting up
the new animation.
So we could do this.
We could store it somewhere.
But where would you store it?
These functions are essentially
kind of pure functions,
as kind of static.
So the only option really is
to store it in the view itself.
But view already offers
such a method for this.
It actually has something
called a view property animator.
Which is [INAUDIBLE] term
would call, View to Animate.
Which allows you to get
access to retrieve any running
animations.
So if we swap out our code
from using object animator
to using
ViewPropertyAnimator instead,
then we get some of
these properties.
So what happens here is when
you call view to animate,
if there's already
an animation running
over that same property,
it will be canceled for us.
And then the new
animation will be run.
So that's exactly what we want.
Even more,
ViewPropertyAnimator offers
this with end action API,
which takes a runable.
So the cool thing about
this is this action
will only be invoked if the
animation runs to completion.
It won't be invoked if
the animation is canceled.
So if a new value comes in, then
the old animation is canceled.
And the action only
runs if it completes,
which is exactly the kind
of properties that we want.
There's still a few problems
with the system here, though.
So what happens if we're
midway through an animation?
Well, we just said
that it's going
to cancel the previous
animation and run a new one.
So that's going to violate
our smooth property
because if we're already
animating the right target
value and a new value comes in,
it will still kind of cancel
it and start again.
So you'll get this kind
of stutter change in it.
We could, for example,
store the current value
that the animator is running,
is currently animating to.
And if a new update to
the same value comes in,
we could perhaps,
skip that update.
But that's not going to
help us out in the case
where we're trying to retarget
to a new value that comes in.
We wait for an animation.
So how are we going to solve
this problem of smoothness?
And there's actually
a library out there,
which I think a
lot of developers
haven't really paid
much attention to,
which is the physics based
property and animation system.
And I think maybe
people have skipped it
because we look at
some of the samples,
or demos, or even our
developer documentation here.
And they see things like
these bouncy animations
and think, hey, that's fine if
I want to make a bouncy effect.
But it's not for me for
general UI animation.
That's a shame because you can
actually very easily turn off
the bounciness.
And what's left is a very
powerful physics-based system,
which has a number
of properties which
are useful for
these kind of cases
that we're trying to solve.
So, for example, if we return
to our square going to the left
or right and we run it
with a physics based spring
system underneath,
because it has
a physics system underneath it.
When you retarget
it to a new value,
it maintains things, like
the velocity, for you.
And it gives us these
properties we're
looking for where if you try
and go to the same place twice,
it maintains the velocity.
Even though it's
starting a new animation.
Or if you retarget to
another destination,
it slows down and
changes direction very,
very smoothly by maintaining
the velocity for you.
So you haven't
looked at springs,
the API looks very similar
to the animated system,
where you have a
subject being animated,
a property which you want to
animate, hit the translation
X, a target value, and
then you call start on it.
But, for me, the
real power comes
when instead of using
start, you use this animate
to final position API.
What this does is if the
animation isn't started,
it will just kick it off.
But, crucially, if an
animation is running,
then it will retarget it.
And this will do that magic of
maintaining the velocity for us
and updating the target value.
So the key thing there was
if the animation was already
running.
So we want something like
that view property animator
we saw before, which
held onto a reference
to any running animation,
such that we can access it,
and cancel it, or update it.
But, unfortunately, view doesn't
have a get spring method,
or like animate has, so
that you can return you
to a handy one of these.
So let's build one.
And so this is an
extension property
I've been playing with,
extension function,
excuse me, adding on view.
Whereby you posit a
property, a view property,
you want to animate.
Such things like, translation
x, or ALPHA, or so on.
And it will return you
a spring animation.
And what I do is I
stash the running spring
as a tag on the view,
so it can hold onto it.
So going for it here, what I do
is I map the property to a key,
such that you can
store it in the tag,
and then try and retrieve it
from the view's tag system.
So if there's one
already running,
we'll get access to that.
Or if there isn't
one already set up,
already stored, then we'll
create a new spring animation
and store it in the views
tag, and then return it.
So a handy little,
small extension function
like this that
helps you get access
to a spring for a given view.
And what that means is that
we can, at the call site,
have a nice clean
something like this.
Well, we just do view.spring
for the translation x.
And, crucially, this will
either return you a new spring
animation or one
that's already running,
which is exactly what we want.
And then we can use that
animator final position syntax
to update your
running animation.
So what might this look
like in our binding function
that we're talking about?
So, here we are, we are using
the ViewPropertyAnimator.
We can sub this out using
the extension function.
And grab access, or
create a new spring,
and animate it to the
final value that we want.
The eagle eyed
amongst you might have
noticed I kind of regressed
in functionality there.
We lost the end listener.
You can of course,
still do this.
This Spring animation system
has listeners, as well.
So, here, we can add
this endless notice
set the visibility
to gone at the end.
But there's a slight
caveat in that,
in order to remove a listener,
which we would have to do,
but at first, ahead of time,
you need a hard reference to it.
You can't just call clear or
any such method like this.
So we need to
store the listener.
Again, I'm using the view
tag here as a handy way
to stash it in the view,
such that before setting up
a new animation, we can cancel
any previous end listeners.
So it's a bit of--
tag, that you have
to be a bit careful,
the way you write
these animations.
That you have to be careful that
they are reentrant, especially.
But the nice thing is that
you can write these functions,
there's only like a handful
these functions you need to do.
You need to write one for like
ALPHA, one for translation,
one for scale,
whatever it might be.
And you stash them
in the library.
And then you can use them
throughout your code base.
Use them in a number of places.
You just write them
a couple times,
end correctly, and then
use them throughout.
Now, looking at
springs, I've kind
of simplified the
creation a little bit.
So just like when you create
an object animator or viewport
animator, you're probably
customizing things
like the interpolation
or the duration.
And Springs don't really
have those concepts
because they're physics based.
They have kind of things
that describe the physics
system underneath it.
So, as such, you probably want
to do like customize the spring
forces to set the damping
ratio and the stiffness.
So the damping ratio
controls that bounciness
we just talked about.
And the stiffness controls
how fast the spring
moves to equilibrium state.
So if you don't
set these, you'll
get these default values.
And these kind of like medium
bouncy, or medium stiffness,
which is kind of what we
saw in the example before.
But I found this in
kind of default values
that are generally
applicable for UI work.
So I added these to
the extension function
to make it very easy to get
this default behavior that
works well for most cases.
So turning off the
bounciness altogether
and sending a slightly
higher stiffness ratio.
But because the
default parameters,
it makes it super
easy that you can just
pass an alternate
value at the call site.
If you want to customize
the animation to make
it slightly snappier,
for example.
So to give you a
real example of this,
we're going to take a look at
a RecyclerView ItemAnimator.
So RecyclerView does a lot
of stuff for you, right?
So using DiffUtil, and fine
grained adapter updates,
it'll give you free
animations, essentially.
So in this example,
I've got the grid
and then when I hit
the shuffle button,
it's moving some items around.
So this is with the
default ItemAnimator.
And you can see it's got
that kind of discontinuous,
or not very smooth--
so it is continuous,
but not very smooth,
animations when items come in.
We can sort this out for this
kind of spring based system.
And we can see that when item,
the new updates, come in,
you can see that they smoothly
animate the final place.
And this might seem like a
kind of toy example for slides.
But this is probably quite
close to what's actually
happening in your apps.
How many apps grab
stuff from the internet
and shove it into
a RecyclerView.
And, you know, this is obviously
like an asynchronous operation.
So updates can come
in at any time.
Or maybe you scroll and new
information is coming in.
By kind of thinking about and
making the animations that
happen when this asynchronous
data kind of comes
back as smooth as
possible, you can really
kind of improve the user
experience in your app.
And so this is a kind of
a slight simplification
of the code because extending
default ItemAnimator
is a little bit involved.
But, essentially, it comes down
to setting up some translations
on some views and then,
when you went to animate it,
you just animate those
translations back down to zero.
So we just used that exact same
extension function we looked up
before to create or grab
an already running spring
animation over the
translation properties
and animate them down to zero.
And this is,
essentially, what it
gets to give you that kind
of nice smooth behavior.
And I'll put this in
gifs in case anyone
wants to take a look.
So we just looked at
kind of general approach
to how to animate
few properties.
But view properties
aren't the only things
that you want to
animate and have
respond to kind of new
states of your application.
Let's go and take a
look at a few classes
that you should be
aware of that can
help you to do this in other
parts of your application.
So, drawables, for example,
often want to set their state.
But you don't always
want that to be
just kind of a static state.
You sometimes want to
animate those changes.
I think everyone is
familiar, hopefully,
with this stateless
drawable class.
So you can define in a check
state, I want this drawable,
and, in an unchecked state,
I want that drawable.
But I don't think
as many people are
super familiar with the
animated version of this.
So this was introduced
in LOLLIPOP API 21.
But it's also part of Jetpacks.
So you can use it back to '16.
And so this lets you, in
addition to those [INAUDIBLE]
states, it lets you
name the states in order
that you can provide a
transition when moving
between any of those states.
And these transitions
the drawable here
can be in the form of an
animated vector drawable,
or an animation drawable.
Kind of like a frame sequence.
So, then, the calling
code becomes super simple.
So in your binding,
you just have
to set, say the check state,
to something in your UI model.
And the class itself,
under the hood,
will take care of running the
transition that you defined
for it.
So this looks
something like this.
So this is from the Android
Developer summer application
where you're tapping
the start and rather
than it just changing, you get
this kind of scale animation.
That can be used like
pretty much everywhere
you can use drawables.
So in the bottom
navigation view,
for example, when you
select a section that
gets into the checked
or selected state,
I forget which, gets set
and we can set a transition
for running between
those states.
These nice little animations,
as you enter the state.
And all of this is
completely declarative.
So all I have to
do is set the icon
to an AnimatedStateListDrawable,
like this.
And I'll get this behavior.
I don't have to maintain the
state or worry about what state
it was in.
It will get canceled
for me or the new one
will get set for
me, automatically.
And we can actually
extend these behaviors
and produce some quite
powerful effects.
So this is the book,
reserve a spot,
button from the Google I/O
application, which, I guess,
everyone in this room
has probably used.
So like reserving
a spot in a session
is quite a critical
action, right?
We don't want to just update the
UI optimistically and say, hey,
you got a ticket, when
you might not have.
We want to actually
do a network request
and confirm that you got a seat
before we tell people that.
Or, that you know, if you're
being wait listed or something.
So you know, there's
quite a lot of information
being communicated
in this button.
But this is actually
[INAUDIBLE] entirely
by a single
AnimatedStateListDrawable.
And so you can see
here that we have
some states in there that have
the different drawable states.
But you might be
looking at and thinking,
what state reserved
or state wait listed?
I've never seen those on
Android classes before.
That's because, I'm not
sure how many people are
familiar with the fact,
that you can actually
add your own states,
two views, which
can be super powerful if
you want to then use it
in conjunction with
this technique,
like an
AnimatedStateListDrawable.
So this can then power
running the right transition
whenever you set one of your
custom states onto a view.
And the way you do
this is, it looks
quite similar to defining custom
attributes for a custom view.
You can define it in at as file,
the states you want to support.
And then we actually wrapped
up this behavior into an enum
because there were a few
things we wanted to change
when the button changes state.
So not just the state that's
kind of this attribute state,
but also we wanted
to change the content
description or
some text that gets
displayed with the buttons.
We wrap this all up
into a enum of states
and setting the attributes
of a state, as well
as these other things.
Then we extend the AppCompat
button, image button class,
in this case, and do
a couple of things.
First, we expose
a property, which
is one of these enum values.
And crucially, in that
whenever that changes,
we call refresh drawable state.
This is your hook into the
view system to say, hey,
my state has changed.
And that, in turn, will
kick off the later updates
to actually run the transitions.
The other thing
you have to do is
you have to override on
create drawable state, which
is essentially how you're
telling the system what
state you are currently in.
So here you have to call this
merge, drawable states method,
and pass in your current state.
This is the kind of
attribute resource, which
if I expand it out
from the enum value,
is this inter array of the
state that you're currently in.
So, by doing this, we can get
some pretty powerful behavior.
So we can have these transitions
between all these given states.
But, as you saw, you know,
this can get quite a lot
because there's six
different states.
If you want to be able
to animate between each
and every one of those
states, you basically
end it with an m by n problem.
So you'd have to kind of define
36 different transitions, which
sounds pretty hard.
So what we did
instead, is we had
a policy of always going
through an intermediary state,
this pending state, where
you see the hourglass going
round and round.
So, as such, if you want to go
from reservable to reserved,
you always go through
this intermediary state.
And that in fact, cut down
the number of transitions
that we had to run from
m by n to just 2 n.
So we only had to write
12 animated vectors.
Luckily, I like writing
animated vectors.
And if you're lucky enough to
be running on API 23 or beyond,
as your main SDK, then
you can use the platforms
AnimatedVectorDrawable
class instead of the support
libraries one, which
also supports reversing.
So you can only right n just
six different transitions
and have them reverse when
going in the opposite direction.
But I guess most people aren't
in that world, just yet.
One note about doing
this kind of thing,
is that we wanted to have this
nice intermediate state, where
it's, like, animating
the hourglass.
One current limitation of the
animated vector drawable class
is that you can't set a repeat
count on an animators set.
You can only set it on Leaf
animator, object animators.
So here where I'm saying that
the repeat counts as minus 1,
which is infinite.
So it is infinitely animate.
You have to be able to structure
animations in such a way
to achieve this.
So how does the
AnimatedStateListDrawable
help us to get into these
kind of goals, which
I set out for my animations?
They only really tick
one box for me here.
They're reentrant.
So it maintains
the state for me.
So, if I enter into a new
state, it will cancel everything
and it will start the
new transition for me
automatically.
It is neither
continuous or smooth.
So it won't kind of halfway
through an animation,
do some kind of magic to
move from that halfway state
to the end state you've defined.
But I think this is pretty
useful for a class which
is out the box.
You don't have to write
any code essentially,
you just have to provide
different transitions
between the states.
So it's a really handy class
to have in you're tool belt
if you need to animate the
transition of drawables.
Closely related, or similar
conceptually, to animator
drawable is the
StateListAnimator,
which actually does some
of the things for views.
So, for example, in
this application,
I have some kind of
friendly conversation.
And when you select
a single comment,
I wanted to have this
kind of transition
where I animate the
elevation and the background
color of the selected comment.
And this is entirely
declaratively powered
by the StateListAnimator class.
So a StateListAnimator
is essentially
a selector where
within each item
tag, within each item,
which is a given state,
you can define these child
animations to be run.
I don't know why it's
not animated selector,
but it is a selector, anyway.
So, here, you can see I
am running an animation
over the background color and
the translationZ property,
whenever you go into
a certain state.
And here, I just
want to point out,
you don't have to
create your own view
states if you do not need them.
So here, we just reused the
Android activated state, which
is available on every view.
So while defining custom view
states is super powerful,
if you have multiple states
you want to move in to
and you want it to be more
meaningful and semantic,
you can just reuse some
of the Android states.
So StateListAnimator, how does
this kind of score on a chart?
So just like an
AnimatedStateListDrawable,
it's reentrant, so it'll
maintain the state.
So if your new state
comes in, it'll
cancel anything that
was previously running
and move you into the new state.
It's kind of semi continuous.
I'll give it like
half a mark here.
And it really comes
down to the fact
that it's just running
these object animators.
And, just like we
looked at before,
you can provide a from
value and a to value.
So just by admitting
the from value,
it will try and query the
current value in order
to run it.
But I said try because
this is, essentially,
a kind of reflection
based approach.
So view has a get
translationZ method on it.
So it can query
the translationZ.
And it will then
say, translationZ
will be continuous.
But there is no get background
color method on view.
Essentially, there is a set
background color method,
which is a convenience method,
that almost takes that color
and coerces it into
a colored drawable
and sets a colored
drawable in view.
But there's no get it for it.
So you have to be a
bit careful about,
if you want to make
this continuous,
about using properties
which are animatable.
That you can read
the current value,
in order to get this
continuous property.
And the last thing
I want to talk about
is an approach to doing
custom view animation.
So let's walk through an
example of what I mean by that.
So in the Google I/O
application again,
we have this filter screen where
you can customize the schedule
to see the topics that
you're interested in.
You're just interested in
Android and sessions, right?
And so this is a
custom view because we
want to have complete control
over the rendering of it.
And there's a few things
going on with this animation.
So, when you select it,
there's the color circle
that both increases in size, as
well as we animate its center
to be in the center of the chip.
We estimate the text position.
And then we also scale
up the drawable, which
is that clear x on the side.
So you could think of a way
of writing this as a custom
animation, whereby
you create animators
for each of those things
which is changing.
When you run those
animations individually.
So an animation for
the circle radius.
One for the circle center.
And then you could perhaps
put them into an animated set
and try and control them and
orchestrate them like that.
But, instead, the way we
went for this is we instead
have a single progress
property, which is just
a Float which runs from 0 to 1.
And we just run a
single animation
over that progress property.
And then what we do is
we drive the rendering
to query that progress property.
So for the circle radius, for
example, we say, what radius
should I be from between this
start value and that end value
for a given progress?
And if you haven't seen
a lerp function before,
it's a very common
animation kind
of utility, which means
linearly interpolate,
which will do just that.
So between this value and this
value for a given progress,
what should I be?
And the key takeaway
here is that if you have
this single progress function.
And then you can just
animate it very easily.
So you can hook
this up to a spring,
like we looked at before,
and have this entirely
be continuous and smooth by
running spring animations
and be able to retarget
it to something else,
rather than having to try and
orchestrate multiple animator
sets, which can be a pain.
Or you could hook
this up to a gesture
perhaps and do something
responding, an animation
responding to a scroll.
Or even hook this
up to something
like motion layout, which lets
you animate a custom property
based on scroll position.
So those are my three
tenants I think that make up
a good animation that
is going to survive
in this kind of reactive world.
But this is really an
ordered list for me.
Essentially, you can think
of it as crafted hierarchy
of animation needs,
where being reentrant
is kind of about correctness.
If you aren't reentrant,
if you're animations
aren't cancelable and
work in the right way
so it can be
recalled, then you're
going to end up in
the incorrect state.
So this is like table stakes.
You have to get this right
in order for animations
to survive in this
reactive world.
Continuous is all
about, I think,
having a smoother
user experience.
So values don't
jump unexpectedly,
which can be very jarring.
And smoothness is almost like
this stretch goal for me.
It's like the icing on the cake.
That rather than just
having things abruptly
change velocity and
change direction,
then it could be a
much nicer experience
to have it do it
in a smooth manner.
But I think it's worth
striving for because what's
the point of animating
it if you're just
going to kind of half ass it.
And so that's my conclusion.
I think it'll be a shame if we,
in this reactive world, if we
were just to give
up on animations.
And I think that these
principles can really
help you hold them in mind in
making better animated apps.
Thanks very much.
[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]